just boy get started with today's video
I do want to thank brilliant fur making
it possible to support by graphics and
learn more about brilliant go to
brilliant org slash buy graphics and
sign up for free his was the brain that
oversaw the most destructive project in
all of human history it's won a war by
unleashing unimaginable horror in the
process catapulting the world into the
nuclear age for his efforts he was
accused of being a Russian spy and
sidelined by the government in this
week's bar graphics we're taking a look
at the life and the work of J robert
Oppenheimer Julius Robert Oppenheimer
was born on April the 22nd 1904 in New
York City his father Julius had fled
Jewish persecution in Europe as a
teenager his mother Bela was also Jewish
with her family having been in New York
for several generations the couple were
married in 1903 with Julius who was
known as Robert being their first child
the second son Frank came along in 1912
when Robert was 8 years old the family
lived in an upscale apartment on New
York's West Side Julius had built a
successful textile importing business
and there was a painter they employed to
cook servants and a chauffeur life for
young Robert was structured and formal
with dinners requiring a suit and tie
[Music]
when Robert was 5 years old the family
took a vacation to Germany there he met
his grandfather who gave him a
collection of minerals he was mesmerised
by the stones leading to a lifelong
obsession with rock collecting when he
was 11 he joined the New York
mineralogical Club a year later
he presented his first scientific paper
Julia sent his son to the best school he
could find the New York School for a
cycle called shat Robert attended from
the 2nd grade right through to college
graduation the focus of the education
was science literature and moral law
Robert was an A grade students who
completely devoted himself to his
studies as a result II didn't have much
of a social life friends they were few
and far between
in fact according to his high school
English teacher he once said I'm the
loneliest man in the world
Robert was extremely socially awkward as
a teenager from the start he considered
himself the smartest guy in the room and
this led to an arrogance which was
off-putting to his peers they were also
put off by his prim and proper nature
[Music]
after graduating from high school he
attended Harvard in order to pursue
serious scientific studies he majored in
chemistry but soon fell in love with
physics he was admitted into graduate
studies in physics and began studying
under the famous experimentalist Percy
Bridgman Alba Naima knew straight away
that this was what he wanted to do with
this life he took a rigorous course load
each semester which allowed him to
graduate in just three years at that
time the American colleges couldn't
compete with the physics laboratories in
Europe the science world was enthralled
with the physics revelations of Albert
Einstein and for any serious
up-and-coming American physicist
crossing the Atlantic was an essential
requirement in 1924 Oppenheimer was
admitted to Cavendish laboratory in
Cambridge England this was one of the
most renowned nuclear physics labs in
the world the lab was under the
direction of Ernest Rutherford who had
already won the Nobel Prize for
splitting the atom Oppenheimer was
assigned to a team of researchers under
the leadership of JJ Thompson who in
1897 had discovered the electron it was
the ultimate setting for a budding
physics genius but Oppenheimer quickly
realized that he wasn't really cut out
for it
he and experimental physics they just
didn't gel he was unable to keep up with
the required workloads and you're almost
suffered a mental breakdown by now he
had developed habit as a chain smoker
and often neglected basic hygiene and
nutritional practices as he got bogged
down with his work but try as he may he
was unable to keep up with the required
workload
a depressed and overwhelmed Oppenheimer
went to see a psychiatrist who told him
that he was suffering from schizophrenia
the prognosis was not good with
long-term institutionalization being the
standard treatment at the time
Oppenheimer refused to believe this
diagnosis he took a vacation to Paris
with his friend Frances Ferguson however
he wasn't exactly good company being
consumed with his own melancholy
Ferguson tried to cheer him up by
breaking the news that he was going to
marry his girlfriend when he heard this
something inside Oppenheimer's fragile
mind snapped and he leaped upon Ferguson
and proceeded to strangle him Baggesen
was able to fend him off but from then
on he became convinced that his friend
had serious mental problems in 1926
Oppenheimer took up a position at the
University of göttingen in Germany this
was the center of theoretical physics in
Europe and Oppenheimer landed right in
the middle of a revolution in the field
he found himself rubbing shoulders with
and learning from the premier names in
quantum physics including Enrico Fermi
Wolfgang Pauli and Verner Heisenberg
here finally Oppenheimer found his
perfect fit in 1927 he received his PhD
in physics over the next two years he
established himself as one of the
leading physicists in Europe publishing
16 papers on quantum physics American
physicists had been left behind by the
European quantum physics revolution many
of the professor's refused to accept the
new counterintuitive theories that went
against the grain of everything they had
known there's left a slew of eager
physicists excited about what was
happening in Europe left out in the cold
Oppenheimer saw himself as the vehicle
by which the European advances in
quantum physics could be introduced to
American physicists
[Music]
his first position back in the States
was as a professor at the University of
California at Berkeley he now have a
head brimming with knowledge and lecture
halls filled with students who were
eager to learn from him the problem was
he didn't know how to teach his social
awkwardness it certainly didn't help
either he would become tongue-tied in
front of his students when he did speak
his ideas would come out as a jumbled
mass of words that simply served to
confuse those in attendance by the end
of his first semester there was just one
student remaining who was taking his
class for credit fortunately though
things got better he applied himself to
his teaching and slowly improved his
ability he managed to cut out the
verbiage to pare down his lectures
making them both understandable and
exciting as a result the students who
referred to him as Opie began flocking
to his lectures within a couple of years
a cult of personality had developed
around simony and his own groupies who
were known as obese boys he relished the
attention and he gave his time
generously to his students often
discussions would be held after class
with students even ending up at his home
the subject usually morphed from physics
to science to art and literature ins
would be fueled by generous quantities
of alcohol while teaching at Berkeley
Oppenheimer continued his physics
research he published more papers on
quantum physics but did not make any
groundbreaking discoveries he did
however convert the Berkeley Lab into a
world-class facility establishing the
new quantum physics as a legitimate
science in America Oppenheimer totally
immersed himself in his work in the
adulation of his students he did not own
a phone a radio or even read the
newspaper when his mind wasn't on
physics he would be studying Hindu
mythology or the ancient classics as a
result he was totally divorced from the
outside world when the Great Depression
struck following the 1929 Wall Street
Crash he was simply none the wiser being
insulated from the effects thanks to a
trust fund now just before we get into
Oppenheimer's work during the war let me
take a quick break to tell you a bit
about brilliant as always I know
mid-roll ads in the middle here they're
not perfect but when we started by
graphics we really wanted it to be a
longer form content channel and well
sponsors they make it possible now
you've heard me talk about brilliant
they're a learning platform that focuses
on active learning this is where you're
given a shor bit of information on a
scientific concept and then you're asked
you solve a problem based on that
information
it's an incredibly effective way to
learn right now brilliant have something
that would be perfect as a new year's
resolution even if that new year's
resolution is coming a little bit late
it's called daily problems and it's five
minutes a day that you can use to
exercise your brain and learn something
new each problem provides you the
context and framework that you need to
tackle it that means you can learn
concepts by applying them that's that
active learning again this sort of short
daily practice can lead you from
curiosity to mastery and far less time
than you would like so go to brilliant
org forward slash by graphics and finish
your day a little smarter and for the
first 200 of you that do so you'll get
20% off the annual subscription and you
can also view all of the wrongs from the
archives so how's that again
brilliant check them out or link in the
description below let's get back to
Oppenheimer
[Music]
it was the effect that the Depression
had on the lives of his students that
made Oppenheimer aware of its
devastating impact this brought him an
awareness of just how much political and
economic events could affect people's
lives this awareness it was strengthened
as he began to take notice of what was
happening in Nazi Germany having Jewish
heritage himself he looked on with great
concern at the rise of Hitler yet it
took a woman to transform Oppenheimer's
political concerns into action Jean
Tatlock was a graduate students he was
studying for a degree in psychology she
was also a member of the Communist Party
talak introduced Oppenheimer to the
world of radical politics he joined a
number of institutions aligned with the
Communists though there is no evidence
that he actually became a card-carrying
member of the Communist Party
however in 1936 his brother Frank moved
California and he did join the party
Oppenheimer he fell in love with Tatlock
and they pursued a tempestuous
relationship between 1936 and 1939 with
the end of his contact with Tatlock his
interest in communism MIT wanes and by
the 1940s he had become rather
disenchanted with it mainly due to
hearing reports of what life was really
like in the Soviet Union yet despite his
later assertions that his flirt with
communism was nothing more than a
boyhood fling accusations that he was a
Russian sympathizer would dog him for
the rest of his life in the wake of his
breakup with Tatlock Oppenheimer began a
relationship with a woman named kitty
Harrison there was however one problem
and that's that kitty was married she
was in fact on her third marriage with
her husband's being a British doctor she
soon divorced the doctor with
Oppenheimer becoming her fourth husband
on November the 1st 1940
[Music]
the bombing of Pearl Harbor on December
7th 1941 changed the lives of senior
physicists in the United States
profoundly overnight their theoretical
research it was being called upon to
help win the war
the first challenge presented to the
physicists was to develop a radar system
the country's top physicists they
gathered at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology's radiation laboratory
ready to throw themselves into what they
thought would be the great work that
would win the war then in September of
1942 work began on a program that proved
to be far more impactful than the radar
project and that was of course the
development of a nuclear bomb in 1939
three German physicists had discovered
nuclear fission which enabled a massive
amount of energy to be released when
neutrons struck a uranium nucleus among
the first to recognize the massive
destructive potential of this technology
if it could be harnessed into the form
of a bomb were two Hungarian scientists
they made it their mission to warn the
presidents of the United States that he
needed to develop such a bomb before the
Germans did but these minor scientists
could not get anyone to listen to them
it was only when they secured the
support of the world famous scientist
Albert Einstein that they were able to
get President Roosevelt's attention
as a direct result of a letter he
received from Einstein Roosevelt created
the Advisory Committee on uranium the
committee began to stockpile uranium
didn't move fast enough for Roosevelt it
was soon dissolved and replaced with the
National Research Defense Council V NRDC
the council was put in the hands of the
army with Brigadier General Leslie
groves having oversight the project was
given an innocuous name as to not give
away its purpose groves called it the
Manhattan Project since 1932
Oppenheimer had been doing his own
private research into nuclear physics he
desperately wanted to get involved in
the project in any way that would
advance America's security in 1941 he
was invited to a top-secret meeting of
scientists to brainstorm how to build a
nuclear bomb he was put in charge of the
physics group who were given the task of
actually designing said bomb by July of
1943 yet officially joins the Manhattan
Project the Manhattan projects it was
not based in one single location rather
there were a number of laboratories
located around the country each tackling
a specific aspect of the project the
biggest challenge was the creation of
the bomb itself and this task was to be
overseen by Oppenheimer the base of the
operation was Los Alamos se deserted
area in the north-central part of New
Mexico this location which was selected
by Oppenheimer himself was to be his
home for the next three years an old
boys school was renovated to serve as
base camp with a number of barracks
being moved into service homes for the
physicists who would work on the project
with a facility ready
Oppenheimer traveled the country in
search of the best scientific minds to
help him build the bomb in addition to
former students he called on top
physicists a number of whom were exons
from Nazi Germany if he was concerned
that he wouldn't find the people he
needed he needn't have been he
originally estimated that he would need
30 people that scientists from all over
the country were energized by the
opportunity and by the end of the war
there were more than 6,000 people living
at Los Alamos divide the primitive
living conditions and the oppressive
desert heat the scientists relished
their time at Los Alamos many of them
mapped their families with them and
spend their time off hiking and skiing
all over the southwest what they weren't
keen on was the seemingly over-the-top
secrecy imposed by the military who were
ever
present every scientist was under
constant surveillance and none more so
than Oppenheimer himself during his time
in Los Alamos the government tapped his
phone opened his mail and had men follow
him everywhere as overseer of the
project Oppenheimer perhaps had not only
contend with the invasion of his own
privacy but to mediate between the often
feisty scientists and the military he
constantly reminded the physicists to
keep the big picture in mind they were
involved in a once-in-a-lifetime
struggle for the very salvation of
mankind by February of 1945 the brains
at Los Alamos had come up with two
designs for the atomic bomb they were
codenamed little boy and fat man little
boy was a uranium based bomb while fat
man used plutonium the scientists were
so confident in the design of little boy
that they deemed it unnecessary to test
but fat man he required testing papa
Dyna decided to test fat man near
Alamogordo New Mexico it was a 60 mile
stretch of desolate landscape from north
to south and 40 miles east to west to
carry out the explosion safely they had
to ensure that the wind was traveling in
the right direction if it wasn't
radioactive dust and debris could travel
over residential areas they had to wait
for what seemed like forever just to get
the right conditions during this time
Oppenheimer was wound up with stress
that things could go wrong and that they
would unleash destruction on the
citizens of New Mexico finally the
conditions were right the explosion took
place on July the 16th 1945 the
resulting flash was visible from three
states the mushroom cloud rose 38,000
feet into the air while the crater that
was blown into the ground was half a
mile wide the other scientists gathered
at the site cheered enthusiastically in
the wake of the explosion but not
Oppenheimer he found the situation apt
to quote from the Hindu text the
Bhagavad Gita now I am become death the
destroyer of worlds
[Music]
the decision to make use of the bombs
was now in the hands of president harry
s truman after much soul-searching he
decided to use it on the japanese in
order to force them to surrender on
August the 6th 1945 the b-29 bomber
Enola Gay dropped little boy over the
city of Hiroshima 90% of the buildings
were instantly destroyed along with
66,000 people however the immediate
Japanese surrender was not forthcoming
on August the 9th fat boy was dropped on
the city of Nagasaki causing 42,000
further deaths the double-whammy it was
too much on August the 14th 1945 Emperor
Hirohito announced the Japanese
surrender when he first heard that the
bombs had brought about the desired
effect Oppenheimer rejoiced along with
the rest of the nation on laser
reflection however he took in the
realization of just what he had
unleashed upon the world
on October the 16th 1945 Oppenheimer
relinquished his position at Los Alamos
he returned to Caltech before taking up
a position as director of the Institute
of Advanced Study at Princeton
University but after three years of
excitement power and cutting-edge
research he found university life or
rather mundane with information about
the Manhattan Project now in the public
domain
Oppenheimer became a household figure
with his face appearing on the cover of
Time magazine
he now used his position of prominence
to lecture around the country on what he
felt the United States should do with
their newfound nuclear technology from
his unique perspective he appreciated
both the technological achievement as
well as the killing potential that had
had unleashed he now felt a
responsibility to ensure that its future
use was for good and not evil he
advocated for international sanctions on
nuclear power but all to no avail at the
same time he appreciated that having
nuclear power was a huge advantage to
the American defense program so rather
than trying to stop it he worked on how
to keep it from going out of control now
in the postwar years a new enemy of the
United States emerged the Soviet Union a
cold war ensued leading to an arms race
between what were now the two world
superpowers the Americans of course they
had the nuclear advantage but all of
that changed in September of 1949 when
the Soviets set off a nuclear explosion
of their own
the Americans were taken off-guard
having believed that the Russians were
well behind them the US government
suspected that spies must have shared
vital information with the Soviets often
I'm the caimans our immediate suspicion
thanks to his former connection with the
Communist Party
[Music]
meanwhile the Americans rush to find a
response to the Russian bomb discussions
were held about a new type of bomb one
that was a thousand times more
destructive than those that had been
dropped over Japan it was a bomb that
was going to be powered by hydrogen
Allah Naima was opposed to the hydrogen
bomb fearing that it would become weapon
of genocide but President Truman decided
to go ahead anyway then the hydrogen
bomb codenamed Mike was exploded in 1952
in November of 1953 the FBI received a
letter from a former government official
alleging that Oppenheimer was a Soviet
spy it was enough to bring the full
power of the McCarthy communist witch
hunt down upon him opening the security
clearance it was immediately revoked a
three-man investigation was then
undertaken as it progressed it became
obvious that he was really being
investigated for his opposition to the
hydrogen bomb project rather than his
supposed ties to the Soviets the
resulting report permanently shut
Oppenheimer out of any involvement in
government affairs due to what it termed
the proof of fundamental defects in his
character following the humiliation of
his ouster from the government
Oppenheimer returned to the Institute
for Advanced Study in 1963 with the
McCarthy Red Scare long in the past the
government's offered an olive branch
Oppenheimer by awarding him the Enrico
Fermi award for excellence in nuclear
research still he never fully recovered
from the humiliation of the 1950's four
years later on February the 18th 1967 he
died of throat cancer he was 62 years
old so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below also don't
forget to check out brilliant you'll
find a link in the description below
subscribe to this channel for brand new
videos several times a week and as
always thank you for watching
you
[Music]